há qualquer coisa para looks ao nesta
tarefa educativa que todos nos dedicamos
vocês pensarem um pouco o que nós
fazemos nós pegamos os melhores produtos
da humanidade da mente humana a melhorar
a melhor ciência a melhor literatura
pegamos na matemática pagamos em tudo o
que via melhor nem damos aos alunos e
aos não se interessam
muitas vezes não se interessa isso é
perturbador
nós que estamos aqui que somos quase
todas ligadas a tarefas educativas a
produção dos professores
ou trabalhamos em instituições de ensino
professores pais e eu sou o pai quatro
crianças quando elas já são todos
grandes e já não precisar - uma que não
tá na universidade
todos nós também profissional momento
podem estar ligados a este problema o
que está a acontecer em muitas
apresentações aqui já foram
identificadas razões muitas lesões são
digamos externas há problemas na sala de
aula há problemas que os negócios bons
problemas de industriais a problemas no
design dos programas disse treinando e
não se deve minimizar isso são problemas
muito sérios do que propunha é que olhar
sus pra um outro aspecto também não pode
ser deixado lá é que os próprios
matérias têm que se mostrar aos alunos o
encanto ea grandeza que ela própria está
aí e algo mais sete que possa pensar a
isso o assunto que está a impressionar
não é assim tão extraordinário eu tenho
dúvidas se o assunto não for assim tão
interessante
meu conselho é que não se ensina o que
nós temos que dar o melhor de facto e ou
se olhar o posicionamento do programa é
o que tenta fazer então que tipo de
atitude é que temos que ter para com o
assunto que o céu distinguiria já dois
aspectos o primeiro é que o assunto tem
que passar a habitar na mento do
educando do aluno do filho na pessoa que
está a ser sujeito educado tem que
passar a
guitar com seu aspecto o problemático o
perturbador o interessante ou inc é
tanto o belo que o torna esse mesmo isto
é uma descrição uma apresentação
meramente descritiva mas que na cabeça
do aluno não é vivida desta maneira é
sempre muito difícil que o intresse e
com boa razão
o segundo aspecto que parece também
importante é que têm que ver com um
fator digamos mais do foro psicológico
tem que ver uma certa é feição pelo tema
o tema tem que interessar o uno tem que
olhar para aquelas um com algum em 3
eu digo isto por israel porque o meu
contacto com a história mostrou por
exemplo no caso da história de portugal
que às vezes tentava literalmente uma
quadratura do círculo ensinava sua
história do nosso próprio país
do modo completamente certo e que às
vezes cínico e depois provas que vão de
simples assim
mas isto é é credível que isso fosse
acontecer então como digo vamos olhar
para um alguns assuntos não tem qualquer
pretensão de ter muita coerência ou
disse nem exaustividade dado pelos
exemplos dos assuntos em que o trabalho
e em que tento no melhor que posso
superar isto
vou falar de descobrimentos eo
investimento sair das nossas cabeças já
estão ou não o vasco da gama outra vez
não né
e já está um conjunto de pressuposições
de vocês conhecem outro assunto certeza
começa em uso no nosso solo certa
maneira também
quando vi informou a all tem essas
projeções já mais ou menos sair já
ouvimos falar isso mas nós temos
realmente eu venho da formação
científica e depois de 15 minutos depois
a tarefas históricas portanto não dá
está fascinado com o momento com os
aspectos históricos e como o seu aspecto
provador surpreendendo muitas vezes
ficou esquecido pela nossa rotina do dia
a dia então vamos ver
no caso dos descobrimentos
dois mil anos ou mais ou menos nós temos
muitos muitos séculos de navegação
européia verão salle no mediterrâneo o
mar muito contido o marido pequenas
distâncias
na versão antiga da antiguidade verdade
média é toda feita o nome da europa e é
claro a outras zonas do globo com
certeza agora só da europa é tudo feito
na europa ou nas costas
são viagens curtas são viagens ponto a
ponto
são viagens nas ruas poucos dias
centenas de quilômetros quando muito e
essa foi a experiência de estudos
europeus que não ganharam e mesmo os
mais famosos já todos ouvimos falar do
lixo que vai de tróia para ythaca embora
não sair dez anos mas enfim não era
grande marinheiro não é de tróia para
item que uma viagem pelas ilhas gregas
não é uma versão viagens e esse é um
ponto importante contidas
subitamente surpreendente menta
de repente se viu isto é parceirão
marinheiros que fizeram ao totalmente em
pensar não começaram a enviar luciano em
longa distância em distâncias de
milhares de quilômetros que implicavam
semanas longe da costa que implicavam
meses e mesmo no mar e que nunca tinha
sido feito
eu não falo de aventureiros sem provar
aventureiros na história da europa e
navegará longa distância
o que nós temos aqui é um design da
reconhecida carreira da índia que é uma
carreira regular comercial estabelecido
portuguesa começaram com viagens vasta
gama no final do século 15
depois não sei como sair e depois porém
adianta toda a europa vai copiar esta
viagem quando quiser navegar para
orientar depois portugueses tivemos bons
pneus que não navegavam por ali mas
também tiveram nas regiões oceânicas e
depois holandeses ingleses franceses e
italianos há 60 anos o que é
absolutamente notável é que esta
transição como compromissos como é que
isto é possível
como foi o que aconteceu aqui como é que
é possível que em pouco tempo
isto é há algumas décadas quem é extinta
mundo está completamento e além disso
mudou mas o que aconteceu pois o que
sucede quando o povo se devem ou
localmente tem contactos apenas locais e
repito passam andar em escala
literalmente planetária é querer e na
índia é primeira escala regular
planetária que não tem consequências
justiça mas todos nível e que importa
perceber e que me parece me sussurra
anton com problemas em comento ligações
que nas causas que nos efeitos a imensa
coisa escrita sobre isto e estes
assuntos são os que nós devemos agora o
comentário com alunos por exemplo uma
das conseqüências é que de repente
começa a conhecer como o mundo era a
questão dos mapas mais famosos para
renata 1507 a partir do momento em que
começar a navegar planetariamente é é
começa à efe que ir àquela forma que
está aí
alguns anos depois um mapa já de uma do
século 16 é praticamente tirando a
língua zonas da ásia é praticamente a
imagem que nós temos do mundo esta
imagem é construída e 50 e 60 anos
a escala da história da europa e
curtíssima e esta imagem foi divina
aquelas viagens extraordinárias
começaram é muito diferente da anterior
aos céus como é diferente
isto era o que pensava que era o mundo
antes que nas recessões começadas por
marinheiros que são e agora entra aqui o
aspecto de anos de afeição pelos nossos
antepassados que era o nosso relógio que
era marinha portuguesa
isso não parece ser contado para a
cobrança e contado e não houve mais
disto há coisas extraordinárias
acontecer mas eu não me interessam pelos
aspectos científicos um aspecto mais
extraordinário do ponto de vista
científico igor explica uma das razões
que fez mudar
foi porque houve muitas vezes dizer que
não havia sim assim portugal portugal
não tenha ciência e as mesmas pessoas
que diziam isso não havia história da
ciência em portugal muitas vezes foi
também diziam que era necessário
tirar uma cultura científica no país
e eu dizia será que não se percebem que
estão em artes nos pés que depois se ter
treinado jovens dizendo que vem duma
zona ou nunca ligou à ciência o mais
fácil é destruir vocações científicas
além disso é objectivamente falso mas
tem uma grande vantagem
como toda a gente sabe quando se diz que
uma coisa não há ficou elevado de ter
que estudar isso é uma grande vantagem
para quem não gosta de estar facto muita
ciência por exemplo a vantagem que os
portugueses conseguiram foi conseguida
devido ao facto de ter incorporado
técnicas matemáticas e astronômicas e
fazem pela primeira vez e por isso temos
instrumentos temos tabelas temos
modificações extraordinárias em
instrumentação que passa de aparelhos
que são muito sofisticados para agora
aparelhos usados no mar mas que são
sintomas modificações sociais ainda mais
profundas porque enquanto os
planisférios plantões férias livres são
instrumentos muito caros que eram apenas
usados em ambientes que corta o ambiente
de grande possibilidade econômica esses
instrumentos agora são usados por
pessoas níveis muito mais vamos assistir
no século 16 em portugal e depois toda a
europa que opera a um impressionante
nome de transferência de conhecimentos
científicos de níveis altos para níveis
mais
isso nunca tinha ocorrido no ocorreu por
uma forma educativa ocorreu pela cidade
a ter pessoas treinadas a fazer essas
viagens mas não foi mais por exemplo foi
em conseqüência destas viagens de longa
distância que se começou a fazer
registos sistemáticos de imensos dados
naturais dia a dia aqui temos instruções
que todos os barcos para pipa tinham
lisboa tenham de fazer aquilo que já
todos os dias na atitude tenham que
estar todos os dias magnetismo tinham
que estar todos os dias e essa
informação era depois recolhida e era
trazida para lisboa é analisada e esta
documentação toda existe é o primeiro
fenômeno de recolha de informação de
interesse científico à escala planetária
aliás a escala planetária e o que
distingue tudo isto que os portugueses
fizeram no século 16
o exemplo mostra o saque do vosso awa
esquerdo
o primeiro documento da história da
humanidade que confirma o conhecimento
da terra como tendo um campo magnético
plantar you machismo é conhecido desde
muito cedo ela chega é conhecido na
china pois chega à europa na idade média
mas pensava que era uma propina de
pedras a ideia muito diferente do que
tudo até real um magnético que é uma
distribuição de magnetismo por toda a
terra aparece pela primeira vez neste
mapa está ali não aparece no mapa inglês
150 anos depois de harley que os
encontrei nos compêndios
surpreendentemente os compêndios de
história português nunca encontraram
este mapa que mostra o progresso
absolutamente extraordinário feito por
um dos nossos antepassados
não é preciso saltar para hiper lulistas
apenas constatar estes factos que são
meus próprios sensacionais os homens na
altura reconheceram isso não somos nós
teríamos que o dizemos pedro não texto
muito declamatório um crime por volta
das 11 às navegações portuguesas dizendo
que são as maiores do mundo as mais
extraordinárias
tudo muito bem mas depois um ponto
crucial é quando vai explicar porque não
invoca essa razão as tradicionais para
que o homem do século já exibiu queria
ou a graça de deus ou a grandeza do rei
ou a força do braço armado dos
almirantes um saber do mar dos
marinheiros mas diz esta grandeza destas
eleições foi feito de vidro o maior
trunfo científicas que os portugueses
tinham na altura é o primeiro texto que
eu conheço em toda a história que e que
funciona é grande sempre ao com vantagem
técnica e um texto feito da nossa
história tem a ver conosco teve com
nossos antepassados
os estrangeiros não ligaram a isso os
céus ligaram e de que maneira
copiaram muito uma das coisas que fiz
foi tomaram como modelo para o seu
desenvolvimento tudo isto e por isso
temos barrichello que o inglês no meio
do século 17 é dizer anunciando agora a
modernidade científica é dizer que é
agora no século 17
temos que fazer no mundo somente o que
os navegadores danos entre os
portugueses e espanhóis fizeram no
século 16 o problema educativo não
dispensa nenhuma daquelas regiões
poderíamos chamar externas mas não pode
de maneira nenhuma omitir uma reflexão e
um trabalho próprio subiu recuperar da
platex ida é surpresa e é o atrativo dos
assuntos que ensinamos mas esse é um
trabalho que nos toca sobretudo é nós
aos que tucanos e por isso tocamos aqui
o para looks inicial com que comecei
sons com um paradoxo final que não
podemos esquecer é que o problema do que
efetivo só tem verdadeira solução quando
o educador repara que iam próprio quem
fica posta em questão
muito obrigado